CHRIS MCKENZIE: Good morning.
Welcome.
Hi.
I'm Chris McKenzie.
I'm a UX designer on Daydream,
Google's virtual reality
platform.
In the leadup to
releasing Daydream
last year, our team
faced many challenges.
And one of those challenges
that was particularly tricky
was designing for
screens in VR--
making sure that text
was easily readable,
that buttons were easily
clickable and lists
were easily scrollable.
And another challenge was
that this is virtual reality,
and when you hear
those words, your mind
tends to go straight
to the third dimension.
You're thinking of 3D tools,
fantastic environments,
surreal use cases, like I want
to build a castle on Mars.
So these are really juicy,
challenging design problems
to go after.
But what we found was if we ever
had to have the user bring up
a menu of options or read
through a dense amount
of content, or pretty
much read anything,
we found ourselves
designing what
was essentially screens in VR.
And this isn't too surprising.
We're surrounded by screens
in real life all the time.
We're all looking at two large
screens on stage right now.
Some of you are
looking at screens
in the palm of your hand.
A considerable amount of
the content that we consume
is packaged in a 2D form.
And some basic
physiology behind this
is that while we
exist in a 3D world,
we see that world at
a projection of light
hitting the back of our eyes.
And our brain does
a good job of fusing
that together and figuring
out some sense of depth.
But we really only see
what his line of sight.
I can't look around an opaque
object, like this podium,
without physically
moving around it.
And I have to read text
spread out on 2D planes.
I can't read it as a
stack of letters going off
into the distance.
I can't look around them.
So this makes
projected 2D content
a really efficient form
of consuming information.
And this is no different in
VR as it is in real life.
The challenge in VR is that
all of the existing techniques
and tools that we've used
to design for screens,
for real life screens,
didn't necessarily apply,
or they weren't as transferable
into virtual reality.
What I'm going to go over today
is some concepts and ideas
that our team has developed
over time to try and simplify
this problem.
And then my colleague,
Adam Glazier,
is going to go over how we apply
those concepts in practice.
So I'm going to start with
talking about a concept called
virtual screens.
So what if we could
take the basic concepts,
the basic properties of
screens in real life,
boil that down to
its essence, and then
use that as a tool to
design for screens in VR?
This is the basic idea
behind virtual screens.
So what is it that all of
these screens have in common?
To start, they all have an
intended viewing distance,
how far away we've designed
these screens to be viewed.
This can obviously be arranged.
For the screens on
stage here, these
were meant to be seen by
the first row, hopefully all
the way back into the back row.
It's just easiest
to think of this
as what is the optimal distance
that these screens were
intended to be viewed from.
And that intended
viewing distance
will inform the
size of the screen
in addition to the size and
density of the content therein.
So this is a really
important concept
to get across if I want
to design for many screens
across many different distances.
And as content creators,
it's easy to take
for granted all of the
thought and design that
goes into any particular screen
that we're creating content
for.
Now in VR, we have to
do all of that legwork,
and then create the content
that goes on the screen.
And we have to do it for
every type of screen.
We're not just mobile UI
designers or laptop UI
designers.
We're billboard designers.
We're stop sign designers.
We're exit signs across
the room designers.
We have to cover
all of these cases.
One way to do that--
to create content that's
consistent across all
of these different
types of screens--
is to use angular units,
to make sure everything
has the same angular size.
And what I mean by
that is that even
though the A on the
billboard in the back
is much larger than the A on
the smartphone in the front,
from the user's point
of view, they're
going to appear to look
pretty much the same.
This is because they have
the same angular size.
This is a really
powerful concept.
If we can design
all of our layouts
in any sort of
angular unit, that
means that we don't have to care
about how far away the screen
will be placed later on.
It will be just as
readable, whether it's right
up next to the user's
face or 20 meters away.
Now, finding this unit
was a little tricky.
And so the team went on
a little bit of a journey
to figure out what
we should use.
We started with degrees.
It's a very common angular unit.
The problem with
degrees was you only
have 360 of them
for a full rotation.
So it's not a lot of
granularity there.
UIs tend to have more.
So if have a UI that's
60 degrees across, which
is a very large UI, you only
have 60 units to work with.
You're going to have
to deal with decimals,
and decimals are messy
and hard to remember.
In this particular example,
we have an example of--
it's comfortably
readable body text.
And that happens to be 1.375
degrees from what we found
with today's current headsets.
Now, that's just a really
hard number to remember.
So we could step it up, and
we can go to minutes of arc.
These are nice.
You get 60 minutes
of arc per degree.
And you get to use
this fun little tick
mark at the end, which
gives you the fidelity--
definitely 82, I don't have
to deal with decimals anymore.
I have a whole
number to work with,
and that's great, although
82 is a very large number
for readable body text.
That's more of a nit pick.
The problem with minute of
arc, or degrees, or arcminutes,
or arcseconds, is that
all of these angular units
are hard to translate
to an actual size
at a given distance.
So in this case, we have
an A with an angular size
of 82 arcminutes.
And if I were to say that A is
a meter away, how tall is it,
we wouldn't be able
to calculate that
very easily without
pulling out a calculator.
So what our team wanted to do
was basically have its cake
and eat it, too.
We wanted an angular unit that
would not change with distance,
but then could be
easily transferred
to a metric size, an
actual world space
size at a given distance.
Radians do straddle this
line to some extent.
We explored that to
a certain degree--
pun intended-- as well.
But we decided that radians are
bound to the arc of a circle,
and that's just a constraint
that we wouldn't need
to be limited by for our UIs.
So internally, we started
using this unit we call a dmm,
and that stands for
distance-independent
millimeter.
It's kind of a playoff of
the density-independent pixel
from Android that we used
to design UI layouts in.
So what is a dmm?
A dmm can be described as one
millimeter at a meter away.
But it can also be
described as two millimeters
at two meters away,
and a half a millimeter
at a half meter away.
All of these were one dmm.
So it's an angular unit that
just follows a millimeter as it
scales off into the distance.
How do we use these?
Let's look at a more
concrete example.
In the upper left-hand
corner of this diagram,
I have a screen space layout
that I have measured in dmms.
All of my UI elements
are measured in dmms.
It's 400 dmms by 480 dmms tall.
And then down
below, I've applied
that layout in world space to
three separate virtual screens.
All of these virtual screens
have a different intended
viewing distance.
The first screen, the
smallest one on the left,
was intended to be viewed
from one meter away.
I call this the identity
position of a virtual screen.
Nothing really changes too much
here between our screen space
coordinates and our
world space coordinates.
40 dmms tall is 40
millimeters tall.
Easy enough.
Then let's move on
to the second screen.
That was intended to be
viewed two meters away.
So in this case, all we did was
scale that screen up by two.
And now, even though
the screen is twice
as big as the other
screen that was intended
to be viewed one meter
away, from the vantage point
that both of these screens are
intended to be viewed from,
they will look the
same to the user.
They will have the
same angular size.
Text will just as
readable, buttons
will be just as clickable,
and motion will appear
to move the same as well.
So this is really
nice, because I
wouldn't want the large
screen in the background
to be animating slower than
the screens in the foreground
just because the content in it
has to move a further distance.
It would feel too
sluggish or lumbering.
And this is something
that happens in real life
with phones and TVs.
The angular movement-- the
angular motion, I should say,
of the content on those screens
is pretty much the same.
Because otherwise,
you would think
it's too slow or too fast.
Now, if you did walk up to
that screen in the back that
was intended to be viewed three
meters away-- if you walked
all way up to it, it would
appear to be too fast.
It would also appear to
have much too large text,
and the textures in it would
probably be too blurry.
That wouldn't be
the greatest vantage
point to view that screen.
This is OK, because
you're going to get
the same thing if
you walked right
up to your own television.
Neither of these
screens were intended
to be viewed from that
particular distance.
So now we have a consistent
screen space layout system
that we can apply to any
screen at any distance.
And we can come up with
guidelines and components
that are sized once
and scaled later.
This is going to save
us a ton of time.
And it's important to
note that we are not
bound by width and height.
Your screen space-- everything
you're measuring in dmms
can also have z.
Because this is virtual reality.
We have some super
powers here that
go beyond what screens in
real life are bound to.
In this particular case, our UI
elements have some thickness,
and we're also using
depth to indicate hover.
And this can be used
to great effect.
It can also be used
to detrimental effect.
With great power comes
great responsibility.
The rule of thumb
that I like to use
is the further away
you get from a purely
two dimensional representation
of content, the less efficient
it will become at
conveying the idea you're
trying to get across.
So in this case, this
comes in the form of-- we
have thickness to our
elements, so now users
have to see this extra edge
on the lip of these cards.
There's parallax of
foreground content
moving against the background.
There's extra shadows.
Also in VR, my eyes are
converging at different depth
points on this UI.
My eyes are ever so
slightly converging
to hit the labels
versus the backgrounds.
This is extravisual
information that the user
is going to have to process
before they even get
to what your UI is all about.
So again, depth can be
used to great effect,
just within moderation.
Another superpower that
virtual screens have
is the ability to distort or
shape your UI to any contour.
And this is really great.
We can't do this as
much in real life.
But in VR, now we can
have flat screens,
curved screens, folded
screens, detached screens.
They can all be floating
around the user.
And whatever you
do to that contour
is making a statement about
how that screen should be used,
or how the content therein
should be displayed.
So we can put all
these things together.
And then when we put all
these things together,
we need to make sure that our
ergonomic constraints still
fit to the users
that we're actually
making this content for,
and in the use cases
that they're using it for.
And luckily, we can
use dmms to lay out
guidelines for areas that are
in view or just out of view
if the user turns their head.
Adam is going to
get more into detail
about this later when he shows
off some of our guidelines.
One other thing I just
really touched upon,
and that's because it could
really have its own talk,
is input.
This model works really well
for input, and particularly
ray-based input.
Because rays are fairly
predictable things.
They get more and more
frenetic as you get away
from the origin.
And because we're scaling
our UIs with distance,
that means that all
of our hit areas
are also scaling to catch that
ever-growing margin of error.
So we can measure all of
our button hit areas in dmms
as well.
So I just talked about a
lot of different properties
of what makes a virtual screen.
But if you only remember
two of those today,
it's that every virtual
screen has an intended viewing
distance, how far away we
have designed this screen
to be viewed by a user.
And because we've come
up with that rule,
it means that now we can
design our screen UI elements
in a normalized
screen space, measured
in dmms, that won't change
based on the distance
that the screen is actually
going to be viewed from.
Now, how do we use
this in practice?
For that, I'm going
to hand things over
to Adam so he can talk
about how we're applying
these concepts in our process.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GLAZIER: Thanks, Chris.
So over the past
year, we've been
using this system of dmms and
the intended viewing distance
to design our apps for
the Daydream platform
as well as Earth VR, which
is on Oculus and VIVE.
So I'm going to walk you
through how we've done that.
So just to back
up a second, it's
really efficient, when
designing for a mobile screen,
to use a laptop.
You can work really fast.
You can design fast.
The screen density is different,
but you get used to that.
You check your design on your
phone once or twice a day.
You start to build an
understanding of, on my laptop,
text sizes, button
sizes look larger.
But you adapt.
So we can do the
same thing for VR.
We can design on the laptop.
We can start to build a
mental model of the size
and shape of things using dmms,
and then check them every once
in awhile in Daydream.
And this is important
because for those of you who
work with 2D designers
or are 2D designers,
you understand how
much consideration goes
into creating a 2D interface.
And the tools are
optimized for that.
And for 3D, the inverse is true.
If you're used to
building 3D things,
these are extraordinarily
complex tools,
and they are a completely
different way of thinking.
So it's actually
beneficial to be
able to work in these two
domains and have them cross.
So today I'm going
to show you how
we've done this workflow
using Sketch in Unity,
but you could use any 2D app,
like Illustrator, Photoshop,
or any 3D app, like Unreal,
or Maya, or Cinema 4D.
So the way I like to
start is take a screenshot
of the environment
that my UI is going
to be in, exactly where it's
going to be when the user first
gets in.
And if we zoom in
to Sketch, you'll
see that every
pixel equals a dmm.
So this makes it super easy to
do red lines for developers.
So when a font size
is 24, pixel is high,
I know that it's
going to be 24 dmms,
and that that will be readable.
So before we get designing, you
need to understand something
about ergonomics.
There's not just the
ergonomics of your neck,
but there's ergonomics
of your eye.
The human eye can look positive
or minus horizontally and up
and down about 30 to
35 degrees comfortably.
So no matter how wide the field
of view is in your headset--
just imagine a user is sitting
on a couch comfortably.
They're not going to want
to move their head around
too much, and their
eyes aren't going
to want to move more than
about 30, 35 degrees.
So you want to keep your primary
UI elements within this area.
Then the next ergonomic
factor is the neck.
So this is this outer region.
It spans about 120 degrees.
And that takes into account the
amount that the person's eyes
can move plus their neck.
Like I said, sitting
on a couch, this
is the dominant posture for VR.
Even though we all say swivel
chairs are the best, most
people doing VR day over day
end up on the couch or in bed.
Finally, there's
the horizon line.
Ergonomically, people's
heads look down
or face down about minus 10,
plus 10 to plus 15 degrees,
and then our eyes
tend to look up.
So your visual
center ends up being
comfortably around plus six
degrees below the horizon line.
What this means
is you don't want
to have your UIs dead
center in the horizon line,
because users will end
up feeling like they
have to look up to see your UI.
So once we understand
those ergonomics,
now we need to
understand readability.
And based on the screen
density today of, for instance,
the smaller pixel phone, we came
up with these recommended text
sizes that are readable for
people with various eyesight
qualities.
So these text sizes will go
down over time as pixel density
increases.
But right now, this is a safe
set of text sizes to use.
And in terms of the
target size, if you're
using a ray-based input,
like the Daydream controller
to point and click on things,
the minimum hit target size
we found that's comfortable
is about 64 dmms
with 16 dmms of padding.
So this won't go down over time.
The Daydream controller is
within an imperceptible limit
of human muscles.
So while the text sizes
go down, these hit sizes
will stay the same.
And these will be
the same on the VIVE
or any other platform that
has good quality tracking.
So here's an example
of all those things
I've just discussed in a
sketch template to spec.
So everything is
specified in dmms.
All the text sizes are
within the readable limit,
and all the UI is
within the primary zone
that we know is
comfortable for users.
So that's good.
We designed the front of our UI.
Now we need to
tell the developer
how this lives in 3D space.
So here's an example of
we did in Street View.
We put the UI at
2 and 1/2 meters.
The UI is sitting about six
degrees below the horizon line.
Or you could measure
that in millimeters,
which is about 260.
And then as you can see,
the navigation elements
are actually closer to
the user and pointed
towards the user's head.
And then from the top view, we
started with a flat projection,
but we found this to be unfair
to the content on the sides,
because the content
starts to skew.
It just feels a little odd.
The outer cards didn't
feel as important.
So we tried angling the UI.
This works well
for certain things.
But because of our
scrolling mechanism,
it made it more complicated
for the developers
to build scrolling and
this folding effect.
So then we moved to
a cylindrical contour
where all the UI is
being bent on a cylinder.
And as you can see, the
navigation element in the front
is also bent.
This felt really--
it felt really
odd to bend the small elements.
I don't know if it's just being
in this world long enough,
but it just didn't feel right.
So we found that doing
two things-- one,
relaxing the center
point of that cylinder.
So if I go back, you can see
the center point we started.
So it's basically a
cylinder around the user.
And we moved it so
that the center point
is behind the user.
So what that does is it
relaxes that contour of the UI.
It feels a little
less claustrophobic
and a little more natural.
And also, when you have
[INAUDIBLE] tracking,
you get a nicer parallax effect.
And the UI looks better from
multiple angles, versus when
the cylinder is
centered in your head,
it really only looks
good from one angle.
And you'll see that the
smaller nav element is using
just a flat projection here.
So when it gets time
to export your assets,
we recommend exporting
at 1x right now.
But this is going to vary a
lot as screen density goes up.
But for the next
one or two years,
1x will probably be fine.
We found that in
some rare cases,
an engineer might implement
an asset in a particular way
where exporting it at a higher
resolution works better.
But we recommend starting at 1x.
And so what that
means is one pixel--
you export a 240 by 480
asset, and it's 240 by 480.
So when we bring
this into Unity,
you can see here that we have an
empty object called the parent
UI.
And the scale is set to 1.
The position is set
to 1 meter away.
And inside that,
we have a canvas.
And because canvas units
in Unity are set to meters,
we need to scale the
canvas down by 1,000.
And what this does is
it allows us to use dmms
in the canvas element.
So now that the
canvas is scaled down,
whole units, like a button
defined as 100 dmms wide,
we can just type in 100.
We don't have to
mess with decimals.
And so now that we
have this all set up,
we can just move the parent UI.
And we scale it by the
amount we're moving it.
So if we move it to
3, we scale it by 3.
And all of the
elements retain the--
they look the same to the user
from that intended viewing
distance.
So from all of this work, we
put together a sketch file
to get you started.
It's full of UI
components, and we'll
be adding more over
the year to it.
But it's enough
to get you started
with layouts and
buttons and font sizes,
and things like that.
So if you'd like
to get those, just
go to our developers guidelines.
It's developers.google.com/vr.
And just look in the
Resources section.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]